terroralarm in wien ein islamist feuert
um sich und tötete vier menschen
die polizei erschießt den attentäter tag
der entscheidung amerika welt seinen
nächsten präsidenten die beteiligung ist
enorm warnung aus berlin
gesundheitsminister sparen rechnet wegen
corona mit vollen intensivstation
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster genannt willkommen man
einem nachrichten dienstag der es in
sich hat und mit sport den etwas später
norbert lehmann präsentiert bei guten
haben doch von mir in amerika
entscheidet sich gerade ob präsident
trump präsident bleibt oder joe biden
ins weiße haus zieht aber bevor wir
ausführlich in die usa blicken zunächst
zum tödlichen terror in wien
dort hat ein verurteilter islam ist
gestern abend ein massaker angerichtet
heute nahmen die polizei 14 verdächtige
aus seinem umfeld fest
gegen 20 uhr fallen im wiener zentrum
die ersten schüsse in der seitenstetten
gasse in der nähe der hauptsynagoge der
20-jährige anhänger der terror miliz es
ist schwer bewaffnet er tötet vier
menschen darunter auch eine deutsche und
verletzt viele weitere zum teil schwer
die polizei erschießt den angreifer in
österreich herrscht staatstrauer aus
wien wolf christian ulrich die
staatsspitze liegt heute blumen und
kränze nieder
mit einer dreitägigen staatstrauer
gedenkt österreich der opfer des
terroranschlags nach den jüngsten
islamistischen terroranschlägen in
frankreich sieht bundeskanzler kurs auch
nach dem anschlag gestern abend den
radikalisierten islam als bedrohung für
österreich
es ist ein kampf zwischen zivilisation
und barbarei und diesen kampf den werden
wir mit aller entschlossenheit führen
der anschlag trifft wie mitten ins herz
die schüsse fallen in einem beliebten
ausgehviertel am letzten abend vor der
ausgangssperre die ja heute wegen corona
beginnt der attentäter erschießt vier
menschen
danach stundenlang panik in der
innenstadt niemand weiß zu diesem
zeitpunkt wie viele attentäter unterwegs
sind
ein schwer verletzter polizist wird
gerettet weil zwei männer courage zeigen
und ihn aus der gefahrenzone cern wir
haben geschehen er liegt da hilft sie im
heft sind hoch die sanitäter standen
dort aber sie haben sich sie haben sich
getraut der und wir haben uns eigentlich
sollten wir sind einfach einfach rüber
gelaufen
dieses video soll den attentäter zeigen
die polizei erschießt ihn kurze zeit
später wie sich heute herausstellt ein
20 jähriger anhänger des ein
vorbestrafter österreicher dessen
familie aus nord mazedonien stammt in
mehreren städten fahren die die polizei
heute nach weiteren beteiligten helfern
hintermännern nach der durchsuchung der
wohnung fanden mittlerweile 18
hausdurchsuchungen im umfeld des täters
in wien und niederösterreich statt
dabei konnten 14 personen aus dem umfeld
des täters vorläufig festgenommen werden
und sie werden auch derzeit einvernommen
22 schwer verletzt in krankenhaus einige
von ihnen schweben noch in lebensgefahr
ärzte sprechen von schuss und
stichwunden die bürgerinnen und bürger
sind heute angespannt und verunsichert
die innenstadt zu verlassen wie sonst
nie wien trauert
es war ja lange nicht sicher ob der
erschossene der einzige täter ist oder
ob sich noch weitere auf der flucht
befinden ist das inzwischen geklärt
britta hilpert in will
noch nicht ganz die ermittlungen hätten
keine hinweise auf weitere attentäter
ergeben sagte der innenminister vor
kurzem aber er betonte auch die
ermittlungen seien eben noch nicht
abgeschlossen
trotzdem geht man hier zurzeit eher von
einem einzeltäter aus aber es wurden
auch 14 menschen aus dem umfeld des
attentäters vorläufig festgenommen
werden nun verhört vielleicht findet man
da keinen weiteren attentäter aber mit
helfer und unterstützer
jetzt ist auch österreich vom
islamistischen terror getroffen worden
wie geht das land damit um
ja das ist wahrlich ein schock eine
zeitenwende für das sonst so friedliche
österreich seit jahren wenn ich sogar
ins seit jahrzehnten hat man in diesem
land keinen islamistischen
terroranschlag mit todesopfern erlebt
und deshalb hat man die entschuldigung
der innenminister betonte deshalb heute
auch dass der attentäter zwar neben
einem nord mazedonischen noch einen
österreichischen pass hatte aber
erzählte eben auch von dem polizisten
der gerettet wurde dank des beherzten
eingreifens einige österreicher mit
migrationshintergrund die gesammelte
staats und regierungsspitze setzt heute
dem terror eine botschaft des
zusammenhaltes entgegen der
islamistische terror wird unsere
gesellschaft spalten sagte kanzler kurz
heute diesem hass geben wir keinen raum
vielen dank britta hilpert zum terror in
wien senden wir auch ein zdf spezial
gleich hier im anschluss an die
nachrichten weltweit schaut man heute
auf die usa auf die präsidentenwahl gut
240 millionen wahlberechtigte können
entscheiden wer ihr land in die zukunft
führen soll wird donald trump
wiedergewählt oder wird joe biden neuer
präsident fest steht das interesse der
amerikaner ist riesig rund 100 millionen
menschen haben vorab gewählt per
briefwahl oder bei der vorzeitigen
stimmabgabe den early voting
zum vergleich vor vier jahren sind
insgesamt rund 137 millionen menschen
wählen
britta jäger berichtet im osten der usa
ging es als erstes los seit gut sieben
stunden sind hier die wahllokale
geöffnet auch in pinal county florida
stehen sie schon am morgen schlange in
dem bezirk liegen republikaner und
demokraten traditionell kopf an kopf ich
hab für joe biden gestimmt weil ich
glaube dass er unser land zurück bringt
und uns wieder vereint weil er der beste
ist
etwa 100 millionen amerikaner hatten
ihre stimme bereits vorzeitig abgegeben
persönlich oder per brief so viele wie
noch nie
eine hohe wahlbeteiligung könnte ihm
zugute kommen nach einem kirchenbesuch
am morgen erinnert joe biden in
pennsylvania noch einmal daran warum die
amerikaner ihn wählen sollten
ich habe gesagt dass ich die seele
dieses landes wiederherstellen will
da war ich nicht melodramatisch ich will
anstand und ehre ins weiße haus zurück
bringen
kontron selbstbewusst im interview am
morgen mit seinem lieblings länder fox
ob er einen weg noch vor dem endergebnis
verkünden würde will der moderator
wissen ich denke auf die umfragen kann
man nicht viel geben ich glaube dass wir
gewinnen also eigentlich nur wenn wir
gewonnen haben es gibt keinen grund
spiele zu spielen
weiträumig um das weiße haus hat trump
in der nacht einen weiteren zaun
hochziehen lassen sollte er sich
vorzeitig zum gewinner erklären oder das
ergebnis unklar seien sind unruhen in
der hauptstadt nicht auszuschließen dass
us wahlsystem hat eine eigenheit die
amerikaner wählen heute nicht etwa
direkt ihren nächsten präsidenten
sondern nur repräsentanten die dann
später in ihrem namen abstimmen
auf diese wahlmänner und frauen kommt es
also an
wie das genau geht erklärt caroline wie
man jeder bundesstaat hat eine
festgelegte anzahl an wahlleuten wyoming
drei das bevölkerungsreiche kalifornien
der künftige präsident braucht
mindestens 270 wahlleute auf seiner
seite
durch das system der wahlleute gewinnt
nicht immer der oder diejenige mit den
meisten wählerstimmen des landes so
wurde hillary clinton 2016 nicht
präsidentin
obwohl sie fast drei millionen
wählerstimmen mehr hatte donald trump
hatte mehr wahlleute und zog so ins
weiße haus ein
in fast allen staaten gilt das prinzip
winner takes all die partei deren
kandidat von den wlan mehrheitlich
gewählt wird darf alle wahlleute des
jeweiligen bundesstaates bestimmen
selbst wenn das ergebnis noch so knapp
ist und deshalb kommt es gerade auf die
staaten an in denen es knapp ist die
amerikaner nennen see swing states das
sind die staaten in denen mal die
demokraten und mal die republikaner die
meisten stimmen bekommen
besonders umkämpft sind drei staaten in
denen vor vier jahren überraschend
abgewählt wurde
wisconsin michigan und pennsylvania
von dort berichtet katrin eigendorf 20
bis 30 minuten müssen die wähler in den
zellen einer kleinstadt in pennsylvania
an diesem morgen warten die meisten von
ihnen sind republikaner dass donald
trump seit wochen zweifel an der
briefwahl äußert hat viele bewogen trotz
corona pandemie ihre stimme direkt
abzugeben
das hier erst nach schließung der
wahllokale mit der auszählung der
briefwahlstimmen begonnen wird stößt auf
kritik bei stammwählern wir sollten die
ergebnisse heute abend und morgen
erfahren wir sollten nicht drei tage auf
irgend etwas warten müssen
es ist friedlich und doch fürchten viele
der wähler in der kleinstadt dass es so
nicht bleiben wird
es gibt viel was und wir können nur
beten dass alles ruhig verlaufen wird
dass alles gut wird in philadelphia
bereiten sie sich auf proteste vor
sicherheitskräfte beziehen in der
innenstadt am abend position immer
wieder hatte es in den vergangenen
wochen gewalt gegeben
joe biden und donald trump haben in den
letzten tagen noch einmal kräftig
wahlkampf in pennsylvania gemacht beide
wissen die wähler in diesem staat werden
maßgeblich darüber mitentscheiden
als künftiger präsident ins weiße haus
einzieht in philadelphia versuchen die
demokraten vor allem die schwarze urbane
bevölkerung und junge menschen zu
mobilisieren in pennsylvania kann es so
knapp werden dass jede stimme zählt auch
dass eine lehre aus der wahl von 2016
tja wann ist denn frühestens mit einem
klaren ergebnis zu rechnen ist runs im
umkämpften bundesstaat florida könnte es
schon rechtzeitig am abend ein ergebnis
geben denn dort dürfen die stimmen der
briefwähler bereits vor dem heutigen
wahltag ausgezählt werden und florida
hat sich ja in der vergangenheit immer
wieder auch mit blick auf das
landesweite das gesamte ergebnis als
trendsetter ergeben
in anderen umkämpften bundesstaaten wie
beispielsweise pennsylvania oder
michigan kann es allerdings noch tage
dauern bis genau diese stimmen die
stimmen der briefwähler ausgezählt sind
das gefällt präsident tram nicht auch
weil er wohl die briefwähler er an der
seite der demokraten vermutet und so
hören man hört man aus dem weißen haus
trump überlege wohl sich am heutigen
wahlabend vorzeitig selber zum sieger zu
erklären auch wenn eben noch nicht alle
stimmen ausgewertet sind das würde
bedeuten dass die wahlkampf schlacht die
das land jetzt in den vergangenen wochen
gesehen hat nahtlos übergänge in eine
juristische schlacht dauer und ende
offen
vielen dank eines morgen um diese zeit
ist hoffentlich die lage klarer zur
auswahl sendet das zdf ein spezial um 20
uhr 25 und ab 0 uhr 10 können sie wieder
dabei sein die nacht der entscheidung
live bis morgen früh um 7
auch online können sie jederzeit auf dem
aktuellen stand bleiben mit dem
live-blog in unserer zdf heute app zum
thema corona da bleibt die zahl der
neuen ansteckungen auf hohem niveau
das robert koch institut meldet 15 1352
neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden und 131
weitere todesfälle im zusammenhang mit
cupid 19
in den vergangenen 7
tagen haben sich im schnitt täglich 17
1050 menschen neu mit dem virus
angesteckt gestern waren es 16 1340
sicher ist in den kommenden wochen wird
es immer mehr corona intensivpatienten
geben davor haben heute
gesundheitsminister sparen mediziner und
biologen gemeinsam gewarnt ihre
botschaft das deutsche gesundheitssystem
ist stabil
und doch muss jetzt alles getan werden
um es zu entlasten
florian a wo er sich angesteckt hat das
weiß jens spahn wie viele andere bis
heute nicht ko wird aber hat der
gesundheitsminister überstanden heute
einen dank an alle die im
gesundheitssystem arbeiten und eine
warnung
die lage ist ernst die zahl der
infizierten steigt exponentiell
und auch die zahl derjenigen die beatmet
werden müssen steigt stark zu stark noch
sollen zwar gut 7200 intensivbetten in
deutschland frei sein
fraglich aber ob es für diese betten
ausreichend pflegekräfte gibt deren
infektionen und erkrankungen sowie
risiko intakte schwächen uns jetzt in
der situation jetzt zusätzlich sie
fallen aus und stehen uns im alltag
nicht mehr zur verfügung mit anderen
worten tatsächlich ist das nadelöhr für
die versorgung der kommenden wochen die
ausreichende verfügbarkeit von
fachpersonal auf den intensivstationen
ob wie im frühjahr betten frei gehalten
und nicht dringend nötige operationen
verschoben werden sollen will man bald
entscheiden
krankenhäuser würden dafür entschädigt
so der gesundheitsminister
ein weiterer engpass tests alle menschen
mit erkältung zu testen im winter nicht
machbar sinnvoll sei an corona test sagt
das robert koch institut nun vor allem
für menschen mit typischen symptomen
fieber atemnot mangelndem geruchssinn
für patienten aus risikogruppen oder
wenn man dem virus wahrscheinlich
ausgesetzt war
einen silberstreif könnte diese grafik
zeigen der wert der angibt wie viele
menschen ein infizierter ansteckt seit
einigen tagen sinkt der wert das rk ii
noch zurückhaltend das wird sich erst in
den nächsten tagen an
zeigen in welche richtung es weitergeht
und wie stabil das ist außerdem müsste
der wert deutlich unter 1 gesenkt werden
um eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
zweieinhalb monate noch dann will die
cdu ihren neuen vorsitzenden wählen
der parteinachwuchs hat die jetzt schon
seine mitglieder befragt klares ergebnis
friedrich merz liegt bei der jungen
union vorne mit fast 52 prozent
überraschend auf platz zwei norbert
röttgen mit gut 28% armin laschet kommt
mit knapp 20 prozent auf den dritten
platz
die abstimmung gilt als stimmungstest
jahrelang wurde über den ostsee tunnel
im fehmarnbelt gestritten nun hat das
bundesverwaltungsgericht den weg für den
bau frei gemacht der tunnel soll
puttgarden auf der insel fehmarn mit
rödby hauen in dänemark verbinden die
auflagen für den naturschutz seien
ausreichend urteilten die richter in
leipzig geklagt hatten umweltverbände
fährunternehmen und die stadt fehmarn
durch den 18 kilometer langen tunnel
soll sich die reisezeit für autos und
züge deutlich verringern
fast vier tage nach dem schweren
erdbeben in der ägäis sprechen die
rettungskräfte von einem wunder
sie konnten ein kleines mädchen lebend
aus den trümmern befreien
91 stunden nach dem beben ein helfer
hatte ihre stimme gehört die dreijährige
habe ihm nach wasser und befragt und
jetzt die arbeit in der champions league
da tritt heute abend menschen behandelt
das dritte spiel in der sogenannten
gruppe h der hammer gruppe sowohl gegen
real madrid als auch inter mailand
führte die borussia kurz bis kurz vor
abpfiff kassierte dann zweimal den
ausgleich heute geht es gegen den
ukrainischen meister schachtjor donezk
den rückenwind mitnehmen aus der
bundesliga möchten die gladbacher sieg
gegen leipzig hat gezeigt sie können
einen vorsprung auch verteidigen in der
champions league klagte dass zwei mal
nicht gegen mailand und madrid gelingt
das gegen die tabellenführer schaffte
sie ist jetzt nicht eine mannschaft die
nur gut verteidigt sondern sie haben
natürlich auch viele viele gute
fußballer in ihren reihen
das kommt durch eine starke
brasilianische gruppe im team keine
verständigungsprobleme hatte der
portugiesische trainer castro großes
team will mehr als nur dabei sein in den
gruppenspielen kleines abenteuer werden
soll sondern dass den rolle spielen
wollen dass wir uns auf internationaler
bühne präsentieren wollen
gespielt wird im riesigen olympiastadion
von kiew nach den jüngsten corona
entwicklungen vor leeren rängen nach 22
pflichtspielen in serie ohne sieg heute
ein erfolg für schalke 04 im
nachholspiel der ersten runde im
dfb-pokal gewann königsblau gegen
regionalligist schweinfurt 05 mit 4 zu 1
aufatmen auch beim neuen
handball-bundestrainer alfred gislason
die europäische handball föderation die
hat entschieden das
em-qualifikationsspiel am donnerstag in
düsseldorf gegen bosnien herzegowina
findet statt
vor gut einer stunde hat axel kromer im
teamhotel neues die entsprechende
nachricht vom europäischen
handballverband erhalten die ehs sieht
keinen grund dem antrag der bossen jahr
auf spielverlegung wegen zu vieler
corona fälle stattzugeben 15
das erste qualifikationsspiel machen und
gleichzeitig das erste spiel von alfred
gislason
darauf freuen wir uns dass auch wirklich
glücklich dass diese gehalten behoben
sind genau wie der gegner wird auch das
deutsche team um kapitän uwe gensheimer
in diesen tagen permanent getestet das
ergebnis alle akteure mit einem
negativen befund eine beruhigende
nachricht in dieser unruhigen zeit und
freuen uns auf das spiel am donnerstag
die korona zahlen steigen die
temperaturen sinken wer wünscht sich da
nicht einfach weg zu fliegen
sie tun es wildgänse am morgen als der
mond noch da ist gleiten sie hoch über
niedersachsen ford aus dem kalt
alten land in richtung süden zur sonne
und sehnsuchtsort rückreise im frühjahr
dann wird das leben vielleicht wieder
leichter eine aussicht die öffentlich
noch ist es bei uns ja nicht kalt sogar
die sonne lässt sich derzeit blicken nur
ganz im norden und ganz im süden fällt
morgen etwas regen
einzelheiten gleich von katja honnefer
so viel von uns für den moment mehr gibt
es im heute journal mit marietta slomka
um drei viertel 10
und hier geht es gleich weiter mit
unserem spezial zum terror in wir danken
ihnen für ihr interesse und wünschen
noch einen guten abend und vielleicht
auch wer sich erlauben kann eine
spannende fernseh us wahlnacht bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren da
zieht ein kleines tief entlang des
ärmelkanals weiter nach nordosten das
wird uns heute nacht regenschauer und
gewitter bringen und dieses schmale
regenband das war eine kleine kalt von
und auch die beobachten wir noch in der
nacht denn da fällt zwischen dem
erzgebirge und im oberrhein regen am
meisten wohl an der donau
sonst ist es zum teil auch mal klar mit
diesem starken bis stürmischen
südwestwind gibt es eben einige
regenschauer und gewitter an der nordsee
die temperaturen in der nacht sinken
meist auf 8 bis 4 grad kühler wird hier
vom nordhessischen bergland bis zu
reifen dann die mosel da droht dann
sogar bodenfrost morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen an den alpen nur bei
sieben grad sonst aber werden nochmals
zehn bis zwölf grad erreicht an den
alpen ist auch morgen eher trüb und
zwischen dem oberrhein und dem allgäuer
kann es noch ein bisschen regnen und
auch an der nordsee sind noch einige
schauer unterwegs bei westwind sonst
aber wird es freundlich sonne und wolken
wechseln einander ab und es geht mit
ruhigem wetter in den nächsten tagen
weiter nach nebel und hochnebel zeigt
sich häufig die sonne und die
temperaturen steigen ganz allmählich
etwas an am samstag lägen sie bei elf
bis 15 grad